what other Awards shows go this year's
Oscars was about as beige as you can get
even the traditional red carpet took it
replaced by a beige one but what's got
us all talking for the wrong reasons is
the ever obnoxious Hugh Grant he
seemingly delighted and humiliating
interviewer a supermodel Ashley Graham
on the non-red carpet
what's your favorite thing about coming
to the Oscars
um
it's fascinating it's a it's a the whole
of humanity is here it's uh it's Vanity
Fair what are you wearing tonight then
adjust my suit your suit who made yours
you didn't make it
um I can't remember my tailor what does
it feel like to be in Glass Onion well
I'm barely in it I'm in it for about
three seconds okay all right okay well
thank you so much it was nice to talk to
you yeah all right back to you guys
I mean
[Music]
it went on a bit the Hugh Grant exchange
there with poor old Ashley Graham just
doing a job right if you go on the red
carpet at the Oscar it's all the beige
garbage as it was last night it's the
biggest carpet in Show Business history
it is crawling in journalists the only
purpose of walking down it is to talk to
the media
but all Hugh Grant who hates the media
decided he wanted to present an award of
the Oscar Zone marched down the carpet
and then be a complete douchebag to any
journalist who had the temerity or
supermodels to ask him questions like
what are you wearing which is probably
the most famous question in Hollywood
history to which the answer is I'm
wearing Dolce Gabbana or whatever it is
you're wearing what you don't do is
humiliate and pick on a young
interviewer just trying to do her job
he didn't roll your eyes and walk away
like God have I got to deal with these
idiots
well we've got talk TV presenter Sharon
Osborne has joined me and play writing
author Bonnie Greer Bonnie let me start
with you you you apparently want to
defend this Behavior well you know
Pierce look it wasn't very nice I mean I
wouldn't have done it myself you
wouldn't have done it yourself but the
guy walked up to her he's an actor I
looked at him immediately and knew he
was off cue he had his jacket open his
pot belly was showing I thought uh oh
and why is he on the carpet well I don't
know why does anybody go down you know
actually probably and you know how it is
they probably got him in the film so
they could get the film made and then he
thought let me show him to help my mates
but I really don't want to be here
is there to appear in front of him
and for that
it's a brand of new of you grant is to
be just what he was
don't call people dicks why not
generally what if they are doing Janet
as good as Sharon Osborne Sharon uh
maybe I shouldn't have used the d word
but to me he just behave like a dick I
mean he just he just treated Ashley
Graham I felt with total disrespect and
he pretended like the job of somebody on
a red carpet if you're an actor at the
Oscars is not to talk to the media or if
you have to look like you're sucking
lemons
yeah I I have to say listen I love Hugh
Grant but he was out of order Ashley
yeah I do I think he's a great actor but
a great idea I was he plays the same
role every time he does a movie and he
did one last the other day
he plays a certain dimwits
the thing is if you don't want to talk
to press if you are bored by it all
don't do the carpet that's the way it is
if you know you're not in the mood to
talk to press don't do it this I
completely agree now the other rule of
the Oscars because it was I gotta say I
watched it all it was long for over
three and a half hours again uh they put
back all those Awards which we thought
we'd got rid of last year for all the
production stuff which is important in
Hollywood to people in the industry but
nobody outside of Hollywood cares about
all these little Awards which then take
up all the time but then somebody forgot
another Golden Rule Sharon which was uh
when you lose you've got to try and
pretend you're happy for the people who
win
but this is something Angela Bassett did
not get the memo on take a look
Jamie Lee
[Applause]
I mean it's like she literally was
sucking or inhaling a large bottle of
particularly toxic vinegar
um she could not contain her discussion
my argument about this Sharon is she's
supposed to be an actress I mean surely
in that moment what you do is you just
act your way out of it you pretend
you're happy but Jamie Lee Curtis don't
he
yeah it's um
I I listen I I get it the disappointment
that's why I never let Aussie go to
award shows I just won't do it you don't
want to be on camera when you didn't win
but but the thing is Hey listen she she
knew she would be on camera she she did
what she felt so you know she didn't
play the game she didn't pretend she
didn't applaud so you know she's got to
live with it she knew what she was doing
she's such an experienced actress she
knows the game yeah what do you think I
hear he was sharing the same but you
know uh they're actors and I think what
happened last year was Will Smith opened
the door to reality so nobody's
pretending anymore and I have to say
when she didn't know what he was
referring to when he said Vanity Fair
I sort of rolled my eyes too yeah I know
but you can understand because the big
party at the Oscars
I just thought whoa and so he played you
grant and that's what he did okay we've
got two people who didn't get the memo
somebody who did get the memo right
iPhone because I've always felt if I
ever won an Oscar and I admit this is an
unlikely aspiration at this stage
although to remind people I have
appeared as myself in nine movies at a
grossed 2.3 billion dollars you've got
no nomination which means I've actually
grossed more than people like Will Smith
however I don't want to boast about my
movie I'm just going to get out nine
movies 2.3 million in the box office
it's just it's a statistical fact
um but if I ever did win an Oscar I
would make I just think you keep the
speech short heartfelt you thank your
mum you tell a little bit about your
journey to get there and then you melt
the Applause and go away
who won the best supporting actor for
everything everywhere all at once it's
won everything last night I thought
email one of the great Oscar speeches
we'll take a little look at the clip
here
my journey started on a boat I spent a
year in a refugee camp
and somehow I ended up here on
Hollywood's biggest stage
they say stories like this only happen
in the movies I cannot believe it's
happening to me this this is the
American dream
you know what Bonnie that right there
was the American dream yes that was a
beautiful speech yeah but what you're
not accepting
you you like the beautiful parts of the
realness of the Oscars yes and not the
ugly parts of the realness of the Oscars
and that was no no you're missing my
point I like the reality I like Hugh
Grant showing us what a Dickie is I like
uh Angela Bassett showing us she's a bad
loser because it's the truth that's why
I'm not trying to hide it yes it doesn't
mean to say that it's good what they're
doing although we can't criticize I
don't know what good means I like real
and that's what it was even when people
are just behaving graciously well well
you know some people are not like that
on on this one uh Sharon I thought this
guy uh Keith we Quan it was a really
moving speech but also that story what a
story that is he came from Vietnam his
family fled Vietnam in a boat they go to
Hong Kong they eventually come through
the refugee program into America and
there he is winning an Oscar uh and you
think about all the debate going on
right now in the UK about these people
trying to come in on boats some
deservedly some not deserved in so on it
was a vivid reminder that actual genuine
refugees do need help and if they do get
the help they can live a dream like that
absolutely I mean he's living proof but
I mean that speech was so heartfelt I
mean I think everyone all over the world
was so
taken and in tears by his speech have
you been to the Oscar Sharon have you
ever sat through it
yes is it as torturous as people tell me
it is
yeah because you're thirsty and hungry
and you want to go to the bathroom wow
having worked with you for years I've
got to say I've been worked with you for
four years and America's Got Talent if
you were any one of those three things
all hell used to break leaves what was
it what was it like when all three were
the problem
it's uncomfortable it is you get
uncomfortable is it going to be
uncomfortable and I think the one of the
biggest winners of the night was Glenn
Close who was supposed to be there and
presenting an award but got covered at
the last minute and couldn't attack
which I think is the Steve McQueen Great
Escape award uh because I just couldn't
because you have to sit there it's three
and a half hours it's a ceremony but you
have to sit there Bonnie for four and a
half hours I want to escape because of
covet though they get you in an hour
before four and a half hours you sit
there no food no drink
it's a nightmare well have you been to
Canada school Catholic School yeah
that's my background no biggie no biggie
Sharon do you think on the Oscars
generally each year the ratings seem to
dip dip dip dip like all award
ceremonies now in a way the pandemic
sped all this up it's like are people
done with the war ceremonies are they
done with watching a bunch of very rich
very famous people telling each other
how great they are
I think that award shows now aren't
really popular at all I think they're
very passe and it's like oh another
award show another award show Here We Go
Again listen the Oscars years ago were
were fantastic and the hosts were
amazing but it just seems to have been
watered down and down and it just seems
that the hosts are reading off
teleprompter I was also struck last
night uh Bonnie there were a lot of big
stars weren't there all the ones you
normally see like Meryl Streep and all
these you know Tom Cruise couldn't be
bothered James Cameron couldn't be
bothered a lot of the really big iconic
figures in Hollywood just couldn't be
bothered to go I'm with Sharon I grew up
on the Oscars yeah I used to just every
year I wanted to be there it was
glorious they all used to go and it was
incredible everybody was there was a big
band there was music it was
entertainment there was all this now
it's like a corporate event yeah that we
just get invited to and it's very Tweed
yeah and it's very sad I've got the
answer they should have one more next
year go on Sharon
no I was gonna say Bonnie do you
remember when Billy Crystal used oh my
goodness oh my goodness David Niven when
the Streaker went off
brilliant stars who came and you really
said yes you were really anxious you
didn't know who was going to win there
were no odds put out there in the street
where you thought oh I know that movie's
gonna win and it wins you never knew
there were big bands that played off I
have the solution I have a solution yes
can you run its course it's not
glamorous anymore right so what we
should do is kill it off and one more
Oscars next year and we just unleash
Ricky Gervais for four hours yeah and he
basically he buries it he sprayed guns
the entire room and then he has a deep
bow and that's it I mean play they do
the music and he's carried off that
would be it uh Sharon great to see you
great to talk to you Tony lovely to see
you thank you very much indeed